significant not just for the people who
are eligible to receive an additional
dose a fourth dose you put it but also
because it gives us a very clear
indication on the same day we expected
the government to
lift all remaining restrictions on
covered just what their strategy is and
how reliant that strategy is going to be
on on vaccinations moving forward first
of all it's a they're calling it a
spring booster campaign it's not
specific to a particular date it's
really they're offering an additional
date of the vaccine to people who are
over 75 or immunosuppressed that's about
it's more than seven million people who
are over 75 and a half million people
who are in the broadest uh
immunocompromised category we offered
another dose about six months after they
received their last dose which for most
of them will have been a booster vaccine
a third a third dose
now the strategy here is this it's very
much precautionary the jcvr assisting
insisting to us this is not in response
to any new information it's not in
response to any suggestion that vaccine
protection is waning any faster than was
expected we knew protection waned
it's pretty good even against omicron
after three doses for the over 75s
they're currently protected
by about 90 protection for going to
hospital it's dropped to about 88
in uh 10 weeks after that jab so it's a
very modest drop but as we all know from
from previously
small
uh arithmetical changes can add up to a
big statistical one so precautionarily
if you give a fourth a dose a booster in
spring six months after the first one
that should extend protection at least
into this year what's happening now of
course with those restrictions being
lifted the we're expecting the
government to announce an end to
uh mandatory isolation was also
expecting to end
free testing although as you've said a
second ago we're still wasting the
details of that some disagreements over
exactly how it will play out
that does mean a period of uncertainty
we don't quite know what this year is
going to look like that's another reason
i think that jc valley wants to
reinforce that vaccine wall and it shows
how reliant on it we're going to be we
also heard today a confirmation there
will be an autumn booster program as
well so it's highly likely that same
group of people will be offered an
additional booster vaccine uh in the
autumn before the winter when we know
if we are gonna have a problem with cove
it's most likely to be then
and the nhs is going to be most risk
then and also as the data accumulates
those of us in younger age groups
may also be invited for booster
vaccinations that hasn't been ruled out
so again we're looking at the government
reinforcing that vaccine wall because
really effectively after today assuming
those restrictions are lifted it's the
vaccines on which we're entirely reliant
to protect us against kobe 19.